Donc ce soir, nous allons, après le travail qui a été fait, on va dire, sur la définition de ce que doivent être les diacres,
qu'est-ce qu'ils doivent porter comme qualité, ce soir nous allons voir en quoi consiste, on va dire un peu une fiche de poste,
en quoi consiste le travail des diacres.
Et donc il y a trois exemples qui sont importants, qui peuvent nous permettre de comprendre, je résume les exemples,
vous pouvez les trouver dans le livre justement avec lequel nous étudions.
Donc le premier exemple, ça va être par exemple Nicolas, qui est un diacre depuis maintenant trois ans,
et dans son église il n'y a pas d'ancien.
Donc Nicolas est diacre, et Nicolas accorde beaucoup d'importance à sa fonction de diacre.
Donc pour lui, on va même dire que c'est la grande considération, la grande considération pour lui,
c'est que tout est défini par le fait qu'il soit diacre.
Et il peut même être inflexible à un moment, il peut être dur parce qu'il est diacre.
Il y a un autre exemple, un autre exemple d'un frère, donc on va prendre Benjamin qui a été élu diacre,
et lorsqu'il a été ordonné diacre, le pasteur qui sert actuellement dans son église,
comme il dit dans l'exemple, rentrait à peine à la maternelle.
Donc il y a des cas où on va trouver des diacres dans une église qui vont accueillir un jeune pasteur,
un jeune pasteur qui vient d'arriver.
Et Benjamin, il a un problème parce que ce jeune pasteur qui vient d'arriver,
qui est rempli de bonnes intentions, a décidé qu'on va réévaluer les choses,
c'est-à-dire qu'on va essayer de revoir qu'est-ce que c'est un diacre selon la Bible,
quel est l'appel qui est dû à un diacre, quel est le travail d'un diacre.
Et donc Benjamin est assez choqué parce que pour lui,
il n'y avait pas à remettre ces choses en cause,
et il est un peu choqué parce que c'est le jeune qui veut venir,
le pasteur c'est un peu ce jeune qui veut venir bouleverser les choses.
Et il y a un troisième exemple.
Donc les trois exemples que je prends,
ce sont les exemples que vous allez trouver en majorité dans les églises.
Il y a un troisième exemple,
dans les églises où il n'y a pas d'anciens,
mais on va trouver des équipes de diacres.
Donc dans le troisième exemple, il y a Gabriel,
qui sert en tant que président des diacres.
Et depuis, il a affronté des situations dans son église,
des situations difficiles, il a su les résoudre.
Et depuis quelques mois, il y a un pasteur qui est arrivé dans son église,
et le pasteur est en train d'enseigner au sujet du leadership.
Et quand ce pasteur enseigne au sujet du leadership,
il est en train d'enseigner sur les anciens, sur les diacres.
Et il y a quelques-uns qui sont froissés parce qu'ils ont peur
que le pasteur soit en train de remettre en cause leur rôle de diacre.
Ils ne comprennent pas trop ce que le pasteur veut faire en voulant réexaminer les choses.
Mais Gabriel les a encouragés en disant un moment,
nous servons cette église depuis longtemps et de manière fidèle,
mais ça ne veut pas dire que nous n'avons plus rien à apprendre.
Essayons d'écouter ce que le pasteur veut dire
et si c'est conforme à la parole, d'aller dans ce sens-là.
Donc voilà trois exemples, par exemple, d'églises où il n'y a pas d'anciens
et souvent on va retrouver des diacres dans ces églises.
Donc dans les deux chapitres précédents,
on a étudié le caractère des diacres
et on avait noté en effet que le caractère est essentiel pour être diacre,
mais le caractère ne fait pas tout.
Il est nécessaire aussi que le diacre soit compétent pour la chose qu'il a à faire.
Et surtout, comme je le disais tout à l'heure aussi dans la prière,
on ne va pas désigner quelqu'un qui est diacre, quelqu'un qui est oisif.
On ne va pas désigner un diacre.
Un diacre n'est jamais choisi par celui qui est assis, qui ne fait rien
et qui regarde tous les autres bouger autour de lui.
On va désigner un diacre en fonction de la façon dont on voit
qu'il est en train de servir la communauté,
d'apporter quelque chose dans la communauté.
Donc c'est pour ça que dans ce sens, nous allons étudier ce soir
en quoi consiste l'œuvre diaconale.
Donc on va l'étudier sur trois aspects.
Le premier aspect de l'œuvre diaconale,
et on l'a étudié lorsque nous avons étudié
qu'est-ce que c'était le diacre selon la Bible,
si vous vous souvenez, c'était de repérer
et de répondre à des besoins tangibles,
donc des besoins qui sont là.
Donc, le problème, on avait dit que les anciens de l'église de Jérusalem
avaient été confrontés à un problème,
c'est qu'à un moment, ils étaient en train de servir,
l'église était en train de grandir,
et il y a eu un problème au niveau de la distribution des repas.
Et les frères se sont plaints parce que, comme on l'avait vu,
il y a des juifs qui étaient venus de toutes les contrées voisines
pour venir célébrer les fêtes juives,
donc la Pentecôte, tout ça.
Et ils se sont convertis, ils sont restés à Jérusalem.
Et c'était les juifs d'origine grecque.
On va dire que c'était les juifs qui avaient une culture grecque
très différente de la culture juive des juifs de Palestine.
Et donc, il y a eu des frictions.
Et quand il y a eu des frictions,
les anciens ont réalisé qu'il y a quelque chose qui n'allait pas.
Ils ont réalisé que dans le travail qu'ils étaient en train de faire,
il y avait quelque chose qui était en train de les détourner
de ce que le Seigneur Jésus leur avait confié.
Donc, à partir de là, ils ont compris l'importance,
parce qu'ils accordaient de l'importance à ça.
Ils n'ont pas décidé de résoudre ça d'eux-mêmes en disant,
on résout ça et puis on passe à autre chose.
Ils ont compris que ça pouvait conduire à un désastre à plus long terme.
Et donc, ils ont décidé d'établir des diacres.
Donc, à l'époque, on ne les a pas appelés des diacres directement.
C'est plus tard que le terme est venu dans l'Église.
Mais ils ont établi sept hommes qui étaient remplis de l'esprit,
qui étaient connus pour leur piété,
et ils ont établis pour se charger de trouver une solution.
Et donc, à partir de là, au niveau de l'Église,
au travers des siècles,
le rôle des diacres s'est beaucoup plus fixé sur le fait
que les diacres étaient là pour des tâches pratiques,
pour pouvoir à des tâches pratiques.
Donc, il faut comprendre que les diacres, en effet,
sont là pour répondre à des besoins tangibles,
mais ce n'est pas tout ce qu'inclut le ministère des diacres.
Et Dieu, ce que Dieu va faire, il va nous le rappeler aussi.
Quand nous voyons, par exemple, l'exemple d'Étienne,
c'est pour dire, quand nous voyons l'exemple d'Étienne,
Étienne va être lapidé après avoir prêché au Sanhédrin.
Et voyez la connaissance de la parole qu'Étienne avait.
Donc, quand nous comprenons le rôle des diacres,
ce n'est pas juste quelqu'un qui est compétent pour quelque chose,
ça va plus au-delà d'une simple capacité à faire une tâche pratique.
Il y a aussi une connaissance de la parole de Dieu
qui est demandée là-dessus.
Donc, le diacre se doit,
quand on voit l'exemple d'Acte 6, comme on avait médité,
les diacres se doivent, ils ne se contentent pas de...
Ils sont là pour aider les anciens.
C'est-à-dire, ils ne se contentent pas de réagir aux problèmes.
Ils sont là aussi pour anticiper les problèmes,
pour pouvoir les résoudre.
Ils réfléchissent dans ce sens-là.
Donc, on va dire un peu,
leur rôle, c'est un peu d'être des protecteurs dans un sens,
de pouvoir veiller sur les anciens,
de s'assurer qu'au travers du travail qu'ils sont en train de faire,
les anciens sont en train de pouvoir avancer efficacement
dans ce que la parole de Dieu leur demande comme travail
qui est la consécration à la prière et à la parole.
Et donc, ça, c'est une recommandation aussi pour de futurs pasteurs,
de futurs pasteurs qui seraient peut-être appelés aussi
à choisir des diacres plus tard.
Il faut toujours s'assurer,
déjà, on va toujours repérer des personnes
qui sont en train de servir les autres,
mais on va aussi s'assurer de prendre des personnes
qui sont en train de servir de façon discrète,
des gens qui ne sont pas en train de s'afficher,
qui n'ont pas ce désir d'être vus dans leur travail.
Donc, à un moment, quand il va servir,
s'il doit servir un verre d'eau,
s'il n'y a aucun frère et soeur qui passe,
il ne va pas servir.
Et dès qu'il y a des gens qui passent,
il va servir le verre pour qu'on voit qu'il est en train de servir.
Non.
Le diacre, c'est quelqu'un qui est discret
dans le travail qu'il est en train de faire.
C'est quelqu'un qui a le sens du sacrifice,
qui est en train de se donner à la communauté
pour pouvoir aider la communauté.
Et c'est quelqu'un qui est en train d'aider,
souvent, même sans qu'on le lui demande.
Mais par contre,
les signes qui doivent nous permettre,
vous voyez, là, nous sommes en train de travailler
à l'évaluation des diacres,
des signes qui doivent nous permettre aussi
de réfléchir à, on va dire,
des drapeaux rouges, des red flags aussi,
pour réfléchir aussi
à l'évaluation de quelqu'un en tant que diacre,
c'est de voir un moment,
c'est de voir quelqu'un
qui n'a pas cette propension à la querelle.
Donc, c'est normal,
un moment,
qu'on va être en train de discuter sur les choses,
d'argumenter,
mais on va toujours le faire dans le sens de paix,
d'apporter de la paix.
Ce n'est pas pour créer plus de problèmes.
Donc, le diacre a cette tendance
à ne pas rechercher la querelle.
Il a cette tendance
à ne pas être dans la désorganisation.
Il a aussi cette tendance à être fiable.
Il est très important,
quand on parle des diacres,
d'avoir des personnes
qui sont fidèles à leurs engagements.
Ce n'est pas quelqu'un,
un moment,
qui ne va pas répondre aux mails,
ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui va,
un moment,
qui va dire un moment,
oui, je vais faire,
et qui finalement ne fait pas.
Parce que là,
ça veut dire qu'il rajoute même encore
du travail sur le dos du pasteur.
Le pasteur lui a confié un travail,
il a dit, je le ferai,
et finalement, il ne l'a pas fait,
et finalement, le pasteur se retrouve
à devoir récupérer ce travail.
Parce que ce que je veux dire,
c'est que généralement,
quand le diacre agit,
c'est toujours pour soulager le pasteur.
Donc, si le diacre n'a pas fait sa tâche,
généralement, ce travail,
finalement, c'est le pasteur
qui va devoir récupérer.
Et donc, la fiabilité est très importante
quand nous sommes en train
de parler d'un diacre.
Et donc, le travail des diacres,
sur la première mission qu'on disait,
c'était le fait de pouvoir répondre
à des besoins tangibles.
Donc, leur but, c'est vraiment
d'aider dans l'église
à ce que, en répondant à certains besoins,
en anticipant certains besoins,
ils soient en train d'alléger
le travail des anciens.
Et là, nous sommes même déjà
en train de répondre à une question
parce que, dans les exemples
que je vous ai pris tout à l'heure,
c'était des églises
où il n'y a pas d'anciens.
Donc, c'est déjà des églises
où il y a des problèmes.
Le rôle des diacres
n'est pas d'administrer l'église.
est de toujours être là
pour soutenir les anciens
qui sont en train d'administrer.
Le deuxième point,
on l'avait aussi évoqué dernièrement,
c'est de protéger
et de promouvoir l'unité de l'église.
Quand on regarde les origines,
donc nous avons étudié acte 6,
quand on regarde les origines du diacona,
nous voyons à un moment
que le diacona a été instauré
pour préserver l'harmonie de l'église.
L'église était menacée.
Elle était menacée d'une,
on va dire, d'une implosion
à cause des repas.
On peut prendre ça à la légère.
Il y a certains qui vont dire,
un moment,
mais qu'est-ce que c'est des repas
devant la parole de Dieu ?
Ça, ce sont des gens trop spirituels.
Ça avait son importance.
Il n'y a pas de problème
qu'on va considérer
comme étant,
on va mettre sous le table.
Non.
Et là, les apôtres
ont considéré la chose
et ont décidé
d'établir des frères
dans ce sens
pour régler le problème.
Et donc,
les diacres,
dans leur institution,
à un moment,
ces sept hommes
ont d'abord été chargés
de protéger l'église
de Jérusalem.
Et même dans ce rôle d'unité,
si vous vous souvenez,
on va remarquer un moment
que quand on regarde
leur nom,
on remarque que ce sont
sept juifs grecs
qui ont été nommés.
C'est-à-dire que
même là,
dans cette confiance
que les apôtres vont avoir,
dans ce souci d'unité,
ils vont même confier
toute la distribution,
la répartition des repas
aux juifs grecs
pour montrer
combien ils avaient confiance
et combien ils étaient
en train de promouvoir
l'unité.
Donc,
un chrétien
qui est habitué
aux querelles,
au fait de
toujours chercher
un peu la petite bête,
on va dire,
ne sera pas caractérisé
pour pouvoir être un diacre.
Un diacre,
c'est quelqu'un
qui a une humilité
qui est palpable,
c'est quelqu'un
qui a un esprit
de douceur.
Un diacre,
c'est quelqu'un
qui sait être flexible.
Il y a des choses
où on va être inflexible
par rapport à
là où la parole est claire,
il y a d'autres choses aussi
où on va savoir aussi
nous adapter aussi,
même dans ce qu'on peut recommander,
dans la façon
dont on va gérer
des problèmes.
Un diacre aussi,
il lui sera demandé
de savoir être flexible.
Il lui sera demandé
de pouvoir affirmer
ses convictions
sans pour autant
agir
comme s'il était
sur un ring.
Donc,
on peut affirmer
nos convictions.
On peut même,
lorsqu'il y a des frères
qui ne savent pas
comment les choses
doivent être faites,
on va à un moment
leur rappeler
ce que les anciens,
ce sur quoi,
parce que dans le diacre,
généralement,
il y a un travail
qui est fait
avec les anciens
de l'église.
Quand on va sur une voie,
on va voir quelle est la voie
qui obéit à ce que
la parole de Dieu recommande.
Et donc,
les anciens délèguent
cette autorité au diacre
et les diacres
peuvent donc expliquer
aux frères et sœurs aussi
pourquoi les choses
sont en train
d'être faites comme ça.
Et donc là,
c'est nécessaire
que le diacre
qui va expliquer
ne soit pas en train
d'être dans un abus
d'autorité,
mais il soit capable
de pouvoir affirmer
les convictions
avec douceur,
avec sagesse.
Et voilà quatre points
qu'on nous donne aussi,
quatre points
qui sont des moyens
de discerner
si un candidat au diaconat
est fait pour ce rôle.
Donc,
pour ceux
à qui j'avais donné,
le premier point,
si quelqu'un peut nous lire
Matthieu 5, verset 9.
Amen.
Merci à ça.
Donc,
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
est en train de nous parler.
Il nous dit,
il ne dit pas juste
qu'heureux ceux
qui ont la paix
ou qui la maintiennent.
Il dit heureux ceux
qui procurent la paix.
Donc,
une des premières choses,
une des premières choses
qui nous permet
de comprendre
si quelqu'un est fait
pour ce rôle,
c'est non seulement
sa capacité
à éviter les conflits,
mais c'est aussi
sa capacité
à promouvoir la paix.
C'est sa capacité
à pouvoir permettre
à ce qu'il y ait
l'harmonie
au sein de l'Église.
Deuxième point,
si quelqu'un peut nous lire
Proverbe 19, verset 11.
Amen.
Merci, mon frère.
Donc,
si on est diacre,
une deuxième qualité
qui est attendue,
c'est cette capacité
à être patient.
C'est cette capacité
à pouvoir manifester
la maîtrise de soi.
C'est cette capacité,
même en affirmant
les convictions,
à les affirmer
avec douceur,
avec respect
de la personne
et non avec un abus
d'autorité.
Et donc,
si on est diacre,
on est aussi capable
de lâcher prise
quand c'est nécessaire.
et il s'agit ici,
comme on a dit,
ce ne sont pas
des questions primaires.
Il ne s'agit pas
de la divinité
de Christ,
de remettre en...
Non,
ce ne sont pas...
Là,
ce sont des questions
plus secondaires,
sur des aspects pratiques
où on saura aussi,
à un moment,
faire preuve
de flexibilité,
ce qui est aussi attendu
d'un diacre.
1 Corinthiens 1,
10 à 11.
Amen.
Ah oui,
vas-y,
continue.
Voilà.
Merci, mon frère.
Donc,
une chose aussi
que Dieu nous montre aussi
et on reviendra là-dessus,
plusieurs fois,
il y a plusieurs textes bibliques
où on voit cette liaison,
c'est entre les anciens
et les diacres.
Par exemple,
dans...
Je ne sais pas
si je retrouve
la frévérance,
c'est dans Philippiens 1,
chapitre 1,
verset 1.
Il nous est dit,
Paul et Timothée,
serviteurs de Jésus-Christ
à tous les saints
en Jésus-Christ
qui sont à Philippe,
aux évêques
et aux diacres.
Donc,
lorsque nous lisons
1 Timothée 3,
nous voyons un moment
que presque
toutes les qualités
qui sont attendues
et qui doivent être manifestées
dans le caractère
d'un chrétien,
d'un ancien,
ce sont ces qualités
aussi qui sont attendues
au niveau d'un diacre.
La seule différence
qu'il y aura à un moment,
mais même là,
je vais bien revenir là-dessus,
c'est que l'ancien
devait avoir
cette capacité à enseigner.
Donc,
quand on parle de ça,
ça ne veut pas dire
que les diacres
n'aient pas cette capacité
à enseigner,
mais ça voulait dire
qu'on doit comprendre
que quand on est aussi
établi ancien,
ça veut dire que son rôle
sera aussi d'apporter
la parole au niveau
de l'assemblée.
Donc,
les diacres sont aussi
des modèles pour le troupeau.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas
que les anciens dans l'Église,
les diacres aussi
se doivent de refléter
Christ
et donc d'être un modèle
pour le troupeau.
Et s'ils doivent être
un modèle pour le troupeau,
ils doivent aussi travailler
à ne pas entretenir
un esprit partisan.
Ils doivent toujours
s'assurer que Christ,
la parole de Dieu,
est toujours plus élevée
que notre culture,
que nos faits de vie.
Donc,
en tant que diacre,
si tu es un diacre,
pour un exemple,
si tu es un diacre
brésilien
dans l'Église,
tu ne vas pas juste
t'occuper un moment
des Brésiliens de l'Église,
tu te dois à tous.
Si tu es un diacre,
si tu es un diacre
avec,
dans un certain sens,
tu ne vas pas dire
à un moment,
moi je préfère à un moment
prendre soin
de ceux qui n'ont pas
de problèmes financiers
parce qu'ils me facilitent
la vie.
Ce n'est pas comme ça
qu'on réfléchit.
Il n'y a pas d'esprit partisan.
Les diacres sont là
en service
pour toute la communauté
et ils doivent s'assurer
que dans le but
de maintenir l'unité
de l'Église,
c'est d'encourager,
par exemple,
quand on parle
de la communion fraternelle,
c'est que toute l'Église
soit en train de vivre
la communion fraternelle.
à un moment que tous les membres
de l'Assemblée,
là aussi c'est un élément,
comme il nous a dit
dans l'enseignement,
c'est vrai que la tête
et le cou sont liés.
Ils ne sont pas directement
liés aux pieds,
mais ils font partie
d'un même corps.
Ce qui sera aussi attendu,
c'est que tu peux avoir
une affinité
avec un frère
beaucoup plus grand
parce que vous êtes
un peu comme la tête
et le cou,
mais ça n'empêche pas
que tu aies aussi
cette relation avec le pied
parce que de toute façon,
s'il y a une douleur
sur l'un ou l'autre,
ça se ressent.
Et donc,
l'encouragement à un moment,
c'est que nous devons
être proactifs
à une communion fraternelle
avec tous les membres
de l'Église,
autant que nous le pouvons.
Nous ne devons pas juste
être en train de choisir
une catégorie de personnes
vers lesquelles nous allons
parce que ça nous arrange.
Et le travail d'un diacre
sera de s'assurer justement
que cet esprit partisan
ne soit pas développé
dans l'Église,
que l'unité,
quand on parle de l'unité,
c'est que la communion fraternelle,
par ses encouragements,
par exemple,
en faisant un message
dans le groupe,
en rappelant la communion fraternelle,
ce sera de s'assurer
que toute l'Église
est en train de communier
et qu'il n'y ait pas
qui soit exclu
de la communion fraternelle.
Si Philippiens 4,
ce qu'il avait pris,
Philippiens 4,
verset 2,
Amen.
Donc,
dans cet encouragement,
ce n'est pas seulement
un verset
qui s'adresse aux diacres,
mais nous devons savoir
que les diacres,
comme je vous l'ai dit,
ils doivent avoir
cette propension
à être,
à cette volonté
d'être en accord
avec les uns et les autres.
Et quand on parle de ça,
ce n'est pas un objectif
d'étouffer la personnalité
ou d'empêcher
que les personnes,
parce que quand on dit
j'encourage Évodie et Saint-Tiche
à vivre en plein accord
dans le Seigneur,
il ne s'agit pas
de dire à un moment
que si Évodie
a quelque chose
à dire à Saint-Tiche,
non.
Il s'agit que Évodie
peut avoir des choses
à dire à Saint-Tiche,
mais il faut toujours
s'assurer
que ce soit des choses
qui soient faites
dans la vérité,
dans l'amour
et que ces personnes
soient toujours
en train de ressortir
dans la paix,
de toujours cette promotion
dans la paix
ou un moment
quand quelqu'un
a été exhorté
et là encore,
on rappelle
que quand on manifeste
de l'amour,
on peut aussi manifester
le fait aussi
de mieux manifester
des avertissements
envers un frère
ou une sœur.
Mais quand on manque
d'amour,
quand on ne manifeste
pas de l'amour
et qu'on espère toujours
qu'on soit écouté
par des avertissements,
il se peut que la personne
ne soit pas réceptive.
Donc,
l'encouragement
à vivre en plein accord
dans le Seigneur,
c'est déjà
de s'aimer
l'un et l'autre
et de pouvoir être...
Evodie et Saint-Tiche
ne seront pas d'accord
sur tout,
mais à un moment,
elles vont quand même
vivre dans un plein accord
dans le Seigneur.
Et enfin,
il y a un passage,
mais on ne va pas
le lire entièrement.
C'est un passage
incointien,
chapitre 13.
Je pense que
tout le monde le connaît.
Tous ceux qui ont pu
être à un mariage
au moins une fois
l'ont entendu
au moins un mariage.
Ça fait partie
de ces passages
qui sont un peu
sortis maintenant,
qui sont un peu déformés
de leur cadre
parce qu'on les utilise
pour exhorter
les mariés.
Mais il faut rappeler
que le cadre
dans lequel Paul l'utilise,
c'est pour exhorter
une église
qui est désorganisée.
C'est pour exhorter
une église
où il manque de l'unité,
où il manque de l'amour.
Et donc,
Paul est en train
de leur rappeler
un moment,
il leur rappelait
un moment
ce à quoi
ils devaient tendre.
Donc là,
c'est un exemple
presque pour
clôturer un peu
sur ce deuxième point.
Ça nous permet
d'évaluer.
C'est-à-dire que
si quelqu'un
va être appelé
au diakona,
un Corinthien 13
va lui permettre
de voir,
de lire,
de pouvoir lire le texte,
de pouvoir voir,
de pouvoir évaluer
déjà personnellement.
Et ensuite,
on peut même demander,
je pense même
pour chacun d'entre nous,
on peut
étudier
un Corinthien 13,
on peut même demander
à des personnes
qui nous connaissent bien,
des personnes
qui nous connaissent bien
dans notre entourage
ou même un responsable
d'église
avec qui nous avons
l'habitude d'échanger,
de pouvoir voir
ce que,
voilà,
de pouvoir voir
avec nous cette évaluation.
Parce que
si à un moment
nous nous évaluons
nous-mêmes,
comme si la Bible
ne sera jamais jugé,
on sera jamais,
on va toujours trouver
des circonstances
atténuantes.
Mais à un moment,
on va avoir des personnes
qui veulent notre bien,
qui nous connaissent bien
et qui vont pouvoir
nous dire,
là je trouve,
en effet,
que dans ton examen
que tu as fait
un Corinthien 13,
ça correspond
ou pas.
Et un Corinthien 13,
verset 7,
nous dit,
voilà comment se manifeste
l'amour,
il pardonne tout,
il croit tout,
il espère tout,
il supporte tout.
Voilà ce qui est attendu,
les qualités
qui sont attendues
d'un diacre.
Ce sont des choses
que Dieu demande
à un ancien aussi,
ce sont des choses
que Dieu demande
à un diacre.
Et à partir de là,
vous allez déjà remarquer
que quand nous faisons
beaucoup d'évaluations
de diacre
dans beaucoup d'églises,
on ne part même pas
sur ces critères-là.
Ça, ce sont les critères
qu'on retrouve
dans Intimité 3,
mais aujourd'hui,
le critère pour établir
un diacre,
ce sera un moment,
son salaire,
ce sera son investissement
social,
ce sera sa compétence
à gérer un budget
et ces choses-là
sont mises de côté.
Voilà ce que Mark Devere
dit à un moment
par rapport à cet aspect
de 1 Corinthien 13.
Il dit,
« Les personnes
qui sont mécontentes
de votre église
ne devraient pas
occuper la fonction
de diacre.
Les diacres ne devraient
jamais faire partie
de ceux qui crient
le plus fort
quand il s'agit
de se plaindre
ou qui ébranlent l'église
par leurs actions
ou leurs attitudes.
Bien au contraire,
ne nominez pas
des diacres
qui ne reconnaissent
pas l'importance
du ministère
de la prédication
et de l'enseignement.
Préférez-leur
des individus
qui désirent
ardemment protéger
celui-ci.
Plus généralement,
choisissez les personnes
qui aiment soutenir
et coopérer
pour servir
en tant que diacre
dans l'église.
Par conséquent,
lorsque vous scrutez
l'assemblée
pour y trouver
vos prochains diacres,
recherchez les personnes
qui possèdent
des dons
d'encouragement. »
Donc,
un diacre,
c'est quelqu'un
qui va de plus en plus
refléter l'amour
tel que Dieu
nous le décrit
dans 1 Corinthien 13.
et c'est un amour
qui va bien au-delà
de ce qu'on peut
le prendre
pour les mariages,
mais rappelons
que c'est d'abord
quelque chose
qui est ordonné
pour toute l'église,
mais qui doit être
encore plus visible
dans la vie
des anciens
et dans la vie
des diacres.
J'espère que
je ne décourage
personne,
s'il y a des candidats.
Le troisième point,
donc,
le premier point,
c'était que les diacres,
dans leur travail,
ils répondent
pour répondre
à des besoins tangibles.
Ce deuxième point,
c'était le fait
de protéger
et de promouvoir
l'unité de l'église.
Le troisième point,
et qui est important
et qui va revenir
avec les exemples
que je vous ai donnés
au début,
c'est de servir
et de soutenir
le ministère des anciens.
Quand nous regardons
le modèle
que Christ nous donne,
et c'est important
qu'on parle
du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
parce que souvent
certaines personnes
vont dire à un moment
« C'est Paul qui a dit ça,
ce sont les prophètes,
Jésus n'a jamais parlé
de telle ou telle chose. »
Donc, non.
Là, le Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
quand le Seigneur Jésus-Christ part,
il établit
les anciens.
Il établit
ses douze disciples,
alors onze,
parce qu'il y a un
qui était parti,
les onze disciples
pour pouvoir
prendre soin
de l'église.
Et ce modèle
va être répandu plus tard.
Plus tard,
c'est ce modèle aussi
quand Paul arrive
à la fin de sa vie
et qui sait
qu'il va bientôt
être arrivé
dans les recommandations
qu'il donne à Timothée.
C'est de prendre soin
de l'église,
que là où Timothée est,
il établit des anciens
qui vont veiller sur l'église
avant qu'ils partent.
Et donc,
Paul aussi,
c'était son modèle aussi.
Voilà pourquoi
dans certaines églises,
il allait rester
pendant un certain nombre
d'années
pour pouvoir former
ces personnes
et s'assurer
que quand il partait,
l'église était
entre les mains
d'hommes matures
dans la parole
qui pouvaient prendre
le relais.
Donc,
nous voyons à un moment
que nulle part,
le bon modèle
serait un modèle
où on va trouver
un moment
que dans une église,
il n'y a pas d'anciens,
il y a un pasteur,
il y a des diacres derrière.
Ce n'est pas
le modèle biblique.
Aujourd'hui,
certaines personnes
ont trouvé à un moment
que être diacre
est beaucoup plus facile
qu'être ancien.
Donc,
on a ordonné,
mais là,
c'est encore
une mauvaise interprétation
de la parole.
Quand nous voyons
le dernier chapitre,
le dernier point
qu'on vient de voir,
être diacre,
on demande autant
à un diacre
qu'on demande à un ancien
en termes aussi
même de fruits
qu'il doit porter.
Donc,
aujourd'hui,
c'est vrai qu'à un moment,
dans les exemples
que je vous ai pris,
il y avait des exemples
où dans la plupart des cas,
ils n'avaient pas d'anciens
dans l'église.
Donc,
c'était les diacres
qui occupent une responsabilité,
qui ont même un pouvoir,
qui ont un pouvoir
d'anciens
qu'ils doivent avoir.
Mais ce n'est pas
la structure de l'église.
La parole de Dieu est claire.
Juste à partir
des exemples
que je vous ai pris
du Sien Jésus-Christ
et de Paul,
quand il donne
ses dernières recommandations
en rappelant
l'établissement
des anciens,
ça doit déjà
être suffisant.
Si cette question,
que cette question
soit vue
dans une église aujourd'hui,
si vous êtes
dans une église
à un moment
et que vous n'avez
pas d'anciens
et qu'il n'y a que
des diacres,
votre prière doit être
que Dieu établisse
des anciens
dans l'église,
que Dieu permette
un moment que,
même le fait
qu'un pasteur
soit seul,
ce n'est pas le modèle
que Dieu a recommandé.
On peut commencer
l'église en étant seul,
mais on doit un moment
avancer dans le fait
de trouver des hommes
capables
qui peuvent porter
cette maturité,
qui ne sont pas encore mûrs,
mais qui vont pouvoir
porter cette maturité,
commencer à les former
pour qu'ils soient anciens.
parce que l'église
ne doit pas juste
dépendre comme ça
d'un seul homme.
Dieu donne le modèle
des anciens.
Et donc,
à partir de là,
on voit que les diacres,
dans leur rôle,
les diacres sont là
beaucoup plus
pour servir
en tant qu'assistant
des anciens.
Et il y a un problème.
Si aujourd'hui,
on trouve une église
où les diacres
s'apparentent,
sont presque
des pseudo-anciens,
on va dire
qu'il y a un problème
et que dans ce qu'on doit faire,
on doit revenir
au modèle biblique.
Paul est très clair.
1 Timothée 3,
on a lu tout à l'heure
Philippiens 1.1,
il dit bien
les évêques
et les diacres.
Donc,
à un moment,
Paul montre bien
le rôle qu'il y a.
Il n'y a pas de confusion
dans les rôles.
Il y a le fait
que Dieu établit
les anciens
pour prendre soin.
Il y a les diacres
pour pouvoir soutenir.
Donc,
c'est un autre point
qui est important
aussi dans ça
parce qu'aujourd'hui,
on va venir
sur ce point-là aussi
par rapport
à ce rôle
dans l'église.
On avait un peu abordé ça
de comment l'église
doit réagir
par rapport
au fait de pourvoir
au lien social.
Donc,
une chose qui a rappelé,
c'est que
dans les premiers temps,
on voit bien
quand on lit les écritures,
on voit même
l'histoire de l'église.
Au début,
les diacres
ont été établis
et ils avaient pour charge
de pouvoir prendre soin
des pauvres,
des malades,
toutes ces choses.
Et c'était tout à fait normal
parce qu'au niveau
déjà de l'église,
dans l'environnement
qu'ils avaient,
généralement,
une église n'était jamais
remplie de personnes riches.
Il y a vraiment
le passage du Seigneur Jésus-Christ
qui va nous rappeler
à un moment
comment la richesse
peut être un frein
à l'évangile.
Et donc,
souvent,
dans une grande majorité
des cas,
c'était des personnes pauvres
et il y avait
des actions
qui étaient mises en place
pour pouvoir aider.
Aujourd'hui,
nous rentrons dans un contexte
qui est un peu différent,
mais c'est pour ça
que nous devons toujours
faire attention
à ce que nous restions
toujours dans le modèle
biblique.
et aujourd'hui,
même sur des définitions
qui vont être beaucoup plus proches
de l'original,
vous voyez,
au début,
à cause de la recommandation
qu'on donnait des diacres
qui devaient servir aux tables,
pour beaucoup,
on a défini
que le rôle du diacre,
c'était de servir aux tables.
Ce n'est pas ce que la Bible nous dit.
Dans la racine du mot diacon,
dans ce qu'on va retrouver un moment,
je ne vais pas vous faire
la leçon là-dessus ce soir,
mais l'idée qui est donnée,
c'est que la mission du diacre
est beaucoup plus supérieure
que le fait de servir aux tables.
Le diacre n'est pas juste là
pour servir aux tables,
il n'est pas juste là
pour un aspect pratique,
mais c'est un point
qui va beaucoup plus loin que ça.
Et il peut y avoir un ministère,
il peut y avoir un ministère
où il y a un ministère,
le diacre va manifester
le ministère de compassion,
mais il faut réaliser un moment
que ces besoins,
il y a d'autres besoins,
qui vont se présenter
et dans le rôle que Dieu décrit,
que le diacre est là
pour aider le pasteur,
pour le soulager de certaines tâches,
nous comprenons à un moment
que même si la Bible
n'est pas explicite
sur toutes les tâches
qu'un diacre,
les diacres peuvent porter,
nous voyons quand même
qu'à un moment,
le rôle d'un diacre
va bien au-delà
du fait de servir les tables.
Donc il y a beaucoup plus
d'aspects pratiques là-dessus.
Et
c'est beaucoup riche,
donc à un moment,
c'est pour ça que je ne veux pas
toujours prendre le...
Donc sur l'autre point,
on a abordé ce point
sur Philippiens chapitre 1,
je vais prendre sur un autre point.
Donc,
c'est pour ça que c'est important
pour nous de comprendre,
quand nous comprenons ce rôle,
nous devons comprendre
que les diacres
ne sont pas là
pour agir
comme une sorte
de deuxième pouvoir.
Ce n'est pas ce que la Bible
nous dit.
Philippiens 1,1
nous montre un moment
dans la recommandation,
il est dit
à tous les cinq
en Jésus-Christ
qui sont à Philippe,
aux évêques
et aux diacres.
Donc,
il y a le fait
que les diacres
sont là pour accompagner
les évêques
dans le travail
qu'ils sont en train
de porter.
Et donc,
nous devons faire attention
à un moment
que les diacres
ne soient pas là
pour presque substituer
le travail des anciens
ou pour être
un travail égal
à celui des anciens.
Donc,
un exemple
que Marc Dever
peut donner
que je vais prendre
pour donner
aussi dans notre contexte
parce que
ça nous permettra
de mieux comprendre
si par exemple
les anciens vont dire
qu'il faut que nous allions
à Lyon,
le diacre
ne va pas lui dire
à un moment
non,
ce serait mieux
qu'on aille à Toulouse.
Le diacre
peut avoir ce rôle
où il va dire
à un moment
que vu l'état
du moteur,
vu l'état
de la voiture,
je conseille peut-être
qu'on aille par étape.
On ira peut-être
pas à Lyon
parce qu'il y a peut-être
une étape
qu'on doit franchir avant.
Là,
je ne sais pas
si ça peut être clair
pour vous permettre
de comprendre le travail.
Une fois,
ça a été
une des questions
où nous avons pu
comprendre ça aussi,
c'est que
je vous parlais
dernièrement
des actes de foi
à poser,
mais si par exemple
vous avez quelqu'un
qui est un diacre
et qui est responsable
des finances,
lorsque le pasteur
va dire à un moment
on va avoir un acte
de foi,
on va bénir un frère
qui est missionnaire
quelque part,
on va faire une offrande
et ce frère va dire
à un moment
tu vois l'état
de nos finances,
on ne peut pas faire
d'offrande
parce que si on fait ça,
on va...
Mais le problème
à un moment
c'est que le diacre
n'est pas là
pour s'opposer
à l'ancien,
il peut s'opposer
un moment
s'il y a quelque chose
qui n'est pas fait
bibliquement,
mais dans cet acte
de foi
où par exemple
les pasteurs
où il est important
d'apprendre à l'église
que notre foi
ne dépend pas
de ce que nous avons
dans le compte en banque,
il est important
de poser des actes
de foi
et voilà pourquoi
par exemple
à Bonne Nouvelle,
si vous vous souvenez
quand j'explique
le début de l'église,
on a perdu
90% des membres
au début
à un moment
quand on a commencé
l'église,
la plupart des gens
sont partis
et malgré ça
le pasteur David
a maintenu le fait
même quand on n'avait
pas tellement à donner
donc à un moment
les gens peuvent trouver
ça peut-être ridicule
mais à un moment
on allait peut-être
donner 30 euros
à un missionnaire
c'est-à-dire que
quelqu'un va dire
mais c'est quoi ?
Mais ce qu'il disait
c'était
il faut déjà enseigner
l'église à donner,
il faut qu'on enseigne
l'église,
que l'église apprenne
un moment
à fortifier les frères
qui sont en train
de servir
à fortifier
ceux qui sont en train
d'annoncer l'évangile
que ce soit
dans des associations
en prenant soin d'enfants
ou sur le champ
le champ missionnaire
parce qu'une église
doit apprendre à donner
si une église
n'apprend pas à donner
elle va finalement
se renfermer
sur elle-même
elle va toujours
trouver des excuses
pour ne pas
pourvoir aux besoins
des autres
donc même lorsqu'on n'avait
pas de grandes finances
même s'il fallait envoyer
que 10 euros
à un moment
on envoyait 10 euros
à un missionnaire
et les missionnaires
ils savaient
donc il n'y avait pas
un missionnaire
qui nous a dit une fois
qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de nous donner
ils savaient aussi
ce que ça représentait
qu'on donne
en fonction de ce que
nous pouvons donner
mais il y avait
quelque chose à établir
et bien sûr
certains auraient pu dire
à un moment
mais les finances
ne permettent pas
de faire ça
mais à un moment
le diacre
va être là
pour pouvoir aider
l'ancien
sur point
mais il ne va pas
être là pour dire
à un moment
ce n'est pas ça
que nous devons faire
le diacre est là
pour accompagner l'ancien
dans le travail
qui est fait
et ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que
ce que nous sommes
en train de dire là
nous ne sommes pas
en train de dire
que les anciens
sont infaillibles
non
parce que même
dans des choix
de direction
voilà pourquoi
on parle d'un collège
d'anciens
vous voyez maintenant
le lien
si tu es un pasteur seul
qui a cette tâche
à un moment
ce sera difficile
de pouvoir prendre
souvent de très bonnes décisions
parce qu'il y a des décisions
qui vont requérir
le fait
qu'il y ait un conseil
qui soit fait
que tu puisses prendre
des conseils
à gauche à droite
mais
voilà pourquoi
il est important
quand on parle par exemple
d'une église locale
une église locale
qui va avoir
un conseil d'anciens
c'est le fait
qu'en toute sagesse
en se basant
sur la parole de Dieu
des anciens
vont essayer
de prendre la décision
la plus adéquate
qui va le plus
dans la soumission
à la parole de Dieu
et donc
les anciens ne sont pas
infaillibles
et si à un moment
ils sont en train
d'aller dans un sens
de ce que la parole de Dieu
ne recommande pas
que des principes bibliques
qui sont bien établis
et bien clairs
les anciens ne vont pas
dans ce sens
que tu sois diacre
que tu ne sois pas diacre
tu dois pouvoir
venir voir les anciens
pour leur dire
frère
voilà ce que dit la parole
voilà ce que vous êtes
en train de faire
donc
mais dans une église
qui est
en bonne santé
et mon rappel
d'une église
en bonne santé
ce n'est pas
une église parfaite
c'est une église
qui est soumise
à la parole de Dieu
donc c'est une église
que Dieu est en train
de corriger
et c'est une église
qui se soumet
à la correction de Dieu
pour être le plus biblique
chaque fois
dans tout ce qu'elle peut faire
dans ses décisions
donc dans une église
qui est en bonne santé
les diacres fidèles
vont
envers Dieu
vont toujours
exécuter la vision
et la supervision
ce qui est donné
selon les anciens
ce qui est aussi
important
donc j'ai parlé
de cet aspect
il y a
je voudrais quand même
aussi
il y a des différences
qui sont importantes
aussi
il y a des différences
qui sont importantes
donc là
je continue
sur ce que nous sommes
en train d'aborder
de la séparation
des rôles
et à Eubène
on a été
je ne sais pas
si je peux dire
bénis par cette situation
parce que c'était
une situation assez triste
mais c'était
tout à fait normal
à un moment
il y a une église
avec laquelle
nous nous sommes
unis à un moment
on a envisagé
le fait
que nos membres
puissent se retrouver
parce qu'on avait
des besoins
et voilà
et ce que le pasteur
David a recommandé
et c'était valable
pour chacun des dirigeants
donc à un moment
quand on s'est rencontré
il a dit
ce qu'on va mettre en place
c'est le fait
de réfléchir
à qu'est-ce que c'est
une église
qui est tournée vers la parole
qui est soumise
à la parole
et on va faire
une évaluation
de nous-mêmes
c'est-à-dire que
même par rapport
à ce que nous allons
étudier
du rôle des anciens
du rôle des diacres
parce qu'il y avait
des diacres dans l'équipe
on va vérifier
que nous sommes en train
d'aller dans le sens
de ce que la parole
recommande
et il y a des personnes
qui l'ont très mal prise
en disant
mais le problème
qu'il y avait
c'est que dans le rôle
qu'ils exerçaient
il y avait une certaine confusion
où ils n'étaient pas
directement pasteurs
où ils avaient un rôle
de diacre
mais ils exerçaient
aussi un rôle de pasteur
et les frontières
n'étaient pas bien définies
et ce n'est pas bon
pour l'église
d'avoir cette confusion-là
et voilà pourquoi
il y avait cette proposition
de cette évaluation-là
et voilà pourquoi
je veux revenir là-dessus
donc comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
quand nous étudions
les deux rôles
on va remarquer un moment
que ce que Dieu attend
du caractère d'un ancien
c'est ce que Dieu attend
du caractère d'un diacre
la seule différence
qui va être là un moment
c'est que Dieu
ne va pas poser
comme prérequis
le fait que les diacres
soient en train d'enseigner
il va par contre
poser ce prérequis
que les anciens
soient en train
de porter la parole
dans l'église
donc ça ne veut pas dire
ça ne veut pas dire
quelque part
que les diacres
ne peuvent pas être
en train d'exhorter
l'assemblée
ne peuvent pas être
en train de porter
la parole
quand les anciens
vont peut-être
leur donner à le faire
mais
les diacres
ne doivent jamais
être présentés
comme ayant
étant placés
en autorité
au niveau de l'église
donc il ne s'agit pas
il ne s'agit pas
de
comment on va dire
parce qu'aujourd'hui
le souci
de certains
vont se dire
à un moment
c'est une manœuvre
c'est facile pour un pasteur
de dire ça
parce que le pasteur
ne veut pas
que le diacre
soit peut-être
impliqué
dans certaines décisions
mais il s'agit juste
de suivre le modèle
biblique
le modèle biblique
qui nous est donné
c'est qu'un moment
quand nous lisons
acte 20
verset 28
je vous donne
les références
vous pourrez relire
plus tard
ou intimité 3
verset 1 à 2
nous voyons
au moment
qu'il n'y a que
les anciens
qui sont appelés
à veiller
sur le troupeau
il n'y a que
les anciens
qui sont appelés
à veiller
sur le troupeau
et les diacres
font partie
du troupeau
donc
quand nous sommes
en train de dire ça
c'est très important
de comprendre
parce que nous devons
être détachés
des mauvaises conceptions
d'églises
que nous avons
eu à un moment
ça ne veut jamais dire
que l'assemblée
est en train d'être
spectatrice
de ce qui est en train
de se passer
l'assemblée doit toujours
être pleinement engagée
ce que Dieu nous montre
dans le modèle
que nous avons
à un moment
nous voyons à un moment
que nous avons
les anciens
qui vont veiller
sur le troupeau
nous avons
les diacres
qui vont faciliter
le ministère
que les anciens
sont en train d'exercer
et nous avons
l'assemblée
qui est en train
d'accomplir ce ministère
retenez
parce que je vais
revenir là-dessus
quand on va parler
un peu des éléments
pour les diacres
en parlant
de répondre
aux besoins tangibles
toutes ces choses-là
généralement
quand on parle
des sept hommes
qui ont été établis
pour gérer
les repas
ça ne voulait pas dire
que c'était maintenant
eux qui étaient en train
d'être à la queue
de l'oeuf
pour servir les repas
à Jérusalem
c'était pas ça
le travail qu'ils avaient
c'était de mobiliser
l'assemblée
c'était de coordonner
les choses
et de s'assurer
maintenant
que toute l'assemblée
était en train
de bien agir
pour que tout le monde
ait ses repas
donc le rôle des diacres
le rôle des diacres
n'est pas un diacre
où ils sont en train
on va dire
d'accomplir le ministère
ils sont en train
d'assurer une transition
entre ce que Dieu
recommande aux anciens
de faire
et ce que l'assemblée
va faire
et donc les anciens
vont donner une orientation
selon la parole
les diacres
vont faciliter
le travail des anciens
et c'est l'assemblée
qui accomplit ce rôle
et donc les diacres
auront un rôle
où ils sont en train
de faire un travail
de supervision
ils sont en train
de faire un travail
de coordination
sous la supervision
d'un ancien
et ça nous amène
on va sur des modèles
un peu plus
un peu plus pratiques
pour nous aujourd'hui
on va rentrer un peu
sur des aspects pratiques
de ça
et de réfléchir aussi
à des modèles
pour nous
quand je parle
je suis en train
de parler de ça
parce que maintenant
c'est un peu plus pratique
voilà pourquoi j'ai insisté
deux fois à peu près
sur ce point là
des anciens
qui conduisent le ministère
les diacres
qui facilitent le travail
des anciens
et l'assemblée
qui a accompli le ministère
je peux même dire
que le plus grand
l'exemple le plus facile
pour vous là dessus
ce serait l'exemple
de la conférence
si vous regardez
les conférences EBN
voilà un exemple concret
de ce que je suis en train
de vous dire
c'est à dire un moment
par rapport à ça
c'est pour ça que vous aurez remarqué
que par exemple
dans toutes les
on appelle
les commissions
chacune des commissions
était supervisée
par un des anciens
et
l'ancien supervisait
et il y avait
une personne
qui était en train
de faire un rôle
de diacre
qui rendait compte
à l'ancien
et qui coordonnait
les équipes
mais en tout cas
à un moment
dans le rôle
qu'on faisait à la conférence
nous n'étions pas
en train de coordonner
ces équipes
le jour j'ai hôte
on était en train
de veiller maintenant
à ce que tout soit
bien établi
voilà dans ce sens
où je peux vous donner
un exemple pratique
de ce que je suis en train
de dire
mais
un point que
je voudrais qu'on voit
c'est très important
parce que
aujourd'hui
on a
on a des soucis
on a un peu de soucis
par rapport
c'est un peu une bataille
où il y a une confusion
là dessus
c'est
les anciens
dans le rôle
du ministère
de compassion
alors
comme je disais
tout au fil
de l'histoire
de l'église
on a vu
un moment
que les anciens
ont souvent été chargés
de prendre soin
des pauvres
de ceux
qui étaient
dans la nécessité
et c'était surtout
au niveau de l'église
c'est bien aussi
de le préciser
que chaque fois
la recommandation
généralement
les diacres
c'était les diacres
excusez-moi
je crois que j'ai dit ancien
mais les diacres
prenaient soin
et ça a toujours été fait
légèrement
au sein de l'église
et ça a toujours été
quelque chose
de très important
dans toute l'histoire
de l'église
et aujourd'hui
ça peut être aussi
quelque chose
qui va créer
un peu de confusion
parce que
aujourd'hui
on va
d'abord
c'est un ministère
qui est important
de toute façon
qu'on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas négliger
parce que le fait
vous voyez
ce qu'on a lu
tout à l'heure
pour ceux
qui étaient à la prière
1 Thessaloniciens
chapitre 5
on a parlé
de soutenir
les faibles
on a parlé
de certaines recommandations
qui étaient données
et chaque fois
Paul
chaque fois qu'il a l'occasion
à la fin de ses lettres
il va rappeler
ses recommandations
et d'ailleurs
souvenez-vous
quand ils vont
à Jérusalem
et qu'ils sont en train
de rendre compte
du travail
que Dieu
a accompli
au travers
dans l'Asie mineure
les recommandations
des anciens
de Jérusalem
ce sera d'être fidèle
au message de l'évangile
et de prendre soin
des pauvres
donc dans l'église
ça a toujours été
un ministère important
de manifester
le ministère de compassion
en venant en aide
à ceux qui étaient pauvres
et qui étaient affligés
mais c'est un ministère
qui a d'abord été
généralement tourné
et revenons aussi
au principe biblique
c'est d'abord un ministère
qui est tourné
vers ceux de l'église
et donc
c'est pas mauvais
dans un souci
d'évangélisation
qu'on puisse se tourner
vers des personnes
qui ne sont pas
dans l'église
à qui on va manifester
ce ministère
de compassion
mais il faut faire attention
parce qu'aujourd'hui
le grand problème
la grande bataille
que nous avons
c'est qu'on a
deux mauvaises écoles
qui sont en train
de s'affronter
quand vous regardez
l'histoire de l'église
de tout temps
vous voyez que
ces deux ministères
vont toujours ensemble
on voit les diacres
qui sont en train
de manifester
un ministère
pour prendre soin
des pauvres
et des nécessiteux
et on voit les anciens
qui sont en train
de se consacrer
à l'enseignement
de la parole
et à la prière
mais aujourd'hui
nous allons trouver
des églises
qui vont mettre
un accent très profond
sur le fait
du ministère social
donc on va d'abord
être préoccupé
que si nous sommes
réellement des chrétiens
les chrétiens
se doivent au monde
et on va négliger
l'enseignement
de la parole
parce qu'on a d'abord
mis l'emphase
sur le ministère social
et il y a d'autres églises
aussi en réaction
à ce qu'elles sont
en train de voir
elles vont dire
à un moment
mais ceux-là
sont en train
de perdre la vision
que Dieu nous a confiée
ils vont enlever
ce ministère social
ce ministère d'aide
aux plus nécessiteux
et ils vont se concentrer
juste sur la parole
et ils ne veulent même pas
faire un ministère
qui va
voilà
qui va peut-être
qui vont trouver
et les distraire
mais
ce que nous voyons
je vais dire
la position officielle
quand nous étudions
les écritures
rien que acte 6
et même quand nous regardons
les lettres de Paul
nous voyons
qu'il y a toujours
une emphase
avec les deux
mais par contre
c'est très important
pour nous de garder
à l'esprit
les apôtres
vont comprendre
à un moment
quelle est leur priorité
et ce qui nous est rappelé
par le Seigneur
même à un moment
c'est que l'église
n'est pas là
pour régler les problèmes
de pauvreté
de la terre
l'église n'est pas là
pour éradiquer
la pauvreté
l'église est là
pour éradiquer
la source
de tous les malheurs
de l'homme
le péché
donc la première priorité
des anciens
ne sera jamais
de servir au table
la première priorité
des anciens
sera toujours
de s'assurer
de l'enseignement
de la parole
et de la prière
de l'église
et le rôle
des diacres
un moment
sera de s'assurer
que dans ce travail là
ils sont en train
de soulager
et quand il y a
des besoins
qui vont se présenter
ils sont en train
de répondre
à ces besoins là
mais l'emphase
a toujours été mise
sur la parole
si aujourd'hui
c'est un élément
que j'apporte
face à
ceux qui vont
privilégier
l'évangile social
c'est un aspect
quand nous lisons
toutes les lettres
de Paul
il n'y a pas
trois chapitres
qui sont consacrés
à l'évangile social
et ensuite
trois chapitres
qui sont consacrés
à la théologie
non
tout
il parle de la théologie
mais vers la fin
il va prendre soin
de donner des recommandations
aux frères et sœurs
mais aujourd'hui
on va être dans une inversion
où on va dire
à un moment
que la théologie
le fait d'expliquer
la parole de Dieu
n'est pas prioritaire
mais le fait
que nous devons
par exemple
je ne sais pas
un jugement
mais être dans la rue
on va considérer
le fait d'être
avec une pancarte
Jesus Hug
tout ça
beaucoup plus prioritaire
que d'avoir
des enseignements
solides
et d'ailleurs
voilà pourquoi
dans le travail
je vous encourage
beaucoup
dans le travail
qui est fait actuellement
nous avons dit
avant de ressortir
évangéliser
de pouvoir étudier
ensemble
qu'est-ce que la parole
de Dieu dit
au sujet de l'évangélisation
pour que nous comprenions
ce que la parole de Dieu
dit au sujet
de l'évangélisation
et que nous soyons
en train d'aller
dans le sens
de ce que Dieu veut
parce que si nous n'allons
pas dans ce sens
nous sommes en train
de partir un peu
dans cette situation
où nous sommes en train
de parler
de l'évangile social
nous sommes en train
de parler
d'un rôle
qui n'est pas
toujours correct
mais le rôle correct
que Dieu nous montre
c'est que les deux
vont de pair
ça ne veut pas dire
que ça a été oublié
Paul va mettre
l'accent
sur la théologie
Paul va enseigner
des vérités profondes
de la parole
mais à la fin
il va donner
des recommandations
pour qu'on se souvienne
des pauvres
qu'on soutienne
des faibles
qu'on pense aux veuves
et toutes ces choses
mais il n'en avait pas
fait la priorité
mais ça ne veut pas dire
que ce n'est pas à négliger
le fait qu'il le recommande
chaque fois presque
dans toutes ces lettres
ça veut dire leur importance
mais l'importance
que Paul donnait
c'était d'abord
l'enseignement
de la parole de Dieu
parce que dans son rôle
d'ancien
c'était son ministère
et ensuite
il y avait des diacres
qui pouvaient le soulager
de certaines tâches
qui pouvaient s'occuper
de prendre la collecte
des frères
pour l'église de Jérusalem
quand il y avait
la famine
toutes ces choses là
donc aujourd'hui
il ne s'agit pas
de dire un moment
parce que quand nous avons
ces deux visions
où à un moment
on doit promouvoir
l'évangile
et pas ce ministère
ça veut dire un moment
que le rôle de diacre
on est en train
de l'écraser
et quand on va être
dans un rôle
où toute l'église
est engagée
à l'évangile social
on est aussi en train
d'écraser le rôle
du diacre
mais dans une église saine
il est important
de retrouver chaque fois
ces rôles
qui sont clairement établis
qui sont clairement présentés
et même si une église
n'a pas de diacre
officiellement établi
on va toujours trouver
dans une église aussi
des personnes
qui sont déjà en train
de faire ce ministère
de coordonner ce ministère là
de diacre
et d'abord en priorité
de coordonner ce ministère
de compassion
envers ceux
de l'église
donc
un autre
je pense que
oui
on a encore le temps
donc
l'encouragement
pour nous
chaque fois de comprendre
c'est de
de comprendre
un moment que
le rôle
des diacres
les diacres
peuvent
un moment
ils peuvent
ils peuvent agir
ils peuvent travailler
ils peuvent se concerter
mais il y aura toujours
une soumission
à la direction
que les anciens
sont en train de donner
dans l'église
il y aura toujours
un moment
un fait
de ne pas
ils vont avoir
cette capacité
à prendre des décisions
en autonomie
mais prendre une décision
même au travail
quand nous sommes au travail
nous savons que
quand je prends une décision
en autonomie
ça ne veut pas dire
que je suis en train
d'outrepasser
ce que mon responsable
m'a dit
ça veut dire
un moment que je sais
jusqu'où mes limites
peuvent aller
et quand il est nécessaire
d'en référer
à mon responsable
je vais le faire
donc dans ce travail
qui est recommandé
à un moment
c'est important
de rappeler aussi
même pour ceux
qui sont en train
d'évaluer leur appel
pour être ancien
ça ne veut pas dire
qu'être ancien
on ne va rien faire
pour pouvoir
prendre soin des autres
si aujourd'hui
tu es un ancien
et que tu as la possibilité
de peut-être
recharger la batterie
d'un frère
ou d'une soeur
tu ne vas pas dire
à un moment
tu vas attendre
qu'un diacre arrive
pour recharger
la batterie
du frère ou de la soeur
et tu pourras partir
si tu as la possibilité
de le faire
tu vas le faire
mais le sens
que nous devons comprendre
chaque fois là-dedans
c'est que
le sens
qui est demandé
c'est un sens
de sacrifice
de service
les anciens
sont en train
de servir
la communauté
les diacres
doivent être là aussi
pour servir
la communauté
et
on va essayer
d'aller jusqu'au bout
et là
dans ce service
de la communauté
maintenant
il y a des besoins
qui peuvent apparaître
là je vais vous décrire
quelques ministères
souvent un peu pratiques
qu'on va retrouver
dans plusieurs églises
au niveau des anciens
des diacres
on va trouver
généralement
que les diacres
dans l'église
c'est les diacres
qui vont s'occuper
de prendre soin
de ceux qui peuvent être
malades dans l'assemblée
tristes
qui peuvent être âgés
souvent
pour recevoir
un réconfort
spirituel ou physique
ce sont les diacres
aussi qui vont
souvent se charger
de coordonner
des ministères
d'hospitalité
ce sont les diacres
qui vont se charger
de l'entretien
ou de la maintenance
d'ailleurs
quand on parle
du ménage
dans l'église
ou s'il faut faire
le ménage
et autres
pour tout ce que
nous connaissons
c'est généralement
un rôle qui va
échouer
à un diacre
il y a beaucoup
de
même les aménagements
lors du culte
il y a beaucoup
d'aspects comme ça
beaucoup d'aspects
beaucoup de ministères
qui vont être
confiés
aux diacres
dans ce sens
mais ce que nous
devons comprendre
c'est que
même si ces rôles
ne sont pas
décrits
forcément
dans la Bible
parce qu'il n'y a
nulle part dans la Bible
vous allez trouver
qu'un diacre
doit s'occuper
du stationnement
mais à un moment
il est nécessaire
que quelqu'un
qui ait un rôle
de diacre
et c'est dans le rôle
de service
qu'on comprend
ce rôle de diacre
va par exemple
s'assurer
à un moment
que les frères
par exemple
à la conférence
il y a des frères
qui étaient chargés
à un moment
d'aider les frères
à trouver des places
de stationnement
il va dire à un moment
ah voilà
j'ai repéré des places
vous pouvez aller
vous garer là-bas
vous garer
toutes ces choses
le travail
qu'il est en train
de faire
n'est pas explicitement
expliqué dans la Bible
mais c'est un travail
qui est en train
de décharger
un ancien de l'église
parce que généralement
quand les gens
vont venir
ils vont d'abord dire
j'aimerais
ça c'était toujours
drôle à un moment
j'aimerais parler
à votre pasteur
à un moment
même quand le pasteur
t'a confié
tu dis
mais il m'a confié
il dit non non
je veux parler au pasteur
donc généralement
les gens veulent toujours
parler au responsable
et le diacre
va être là
pour amortir
pour servir de relais
il a cette autorité là
et donc à un moment
au lieu d'aller voir
l'ancien
pour dire
où est-ce que je peux
me garer
autour de l'église américaine
on va aller voir
celui qui fait
ce rôle de diacre
pour lui dire un moment
où est-ce que je peux
me garer
et il va vous indiquer
en disant
ah il y a des places là-bas
et là j'ai vu le rôle
il y a certains
qui l'ont fait
pendant la conférence
qui ont fait ce rôle là
d'orienter les personnes
dans ce sens
donc
généralement
le travail des diacres
c'est un travail
qui va toujours être
un travail assez précis
qui peut être aussi limité
dans le temps
le temps qu'il y ait des choses
qui soient bien mises en place
parce que par exemple
vous voyez que
les sept
qui ont été établis
dans leur rôle de diacre
pour s'assurer
de la coordination
des repas
ils ne sont pas restés
toute leur vie
à faire ça
à un moment
Étienne s'est retrouvé
à évangéliser
il a fini lapidé
Philippe
était évangéliste
et d'ailleurs
on ne le reconnaît pas
dans le titre
Philippe le diacre
en Philippe l'évangéliste
pourtant il faisait partie
de ça
donc ce sont généralement
des rôles
qui vont être limités
dans un certain sens
et qui remplissent
qui sont là
pour un besoin précis
et quand ce besoin précis
peut être rempli
même dans ce rôle là
on peut décharger
la personne de ce rôle
et généralement
il y a des petits rôles
si tu es pasteur
et qu'il y a une équipe
d'anciens
il y a des anciens
qui peuvent porter ce rôle là
mais s'il y a un moment
ils jugent
que le travail
qu'ils sont en train de faire
prend beaucoup de temps
par rapport à ce qu'ils devraient investir
dans la prière
et dans l'enseignement
c'est alors
qu'on va chercher
quelqu'un
qui peut avoir ce rôle
de diacre
pour soulager l'ancien
c'est dans ce sens là
qu'on doit réfléchir à ça
et
alors je
je sais
ce que je peux dire
parce qu'on est en train
d'arriver à la fin
donc
sur la conclusion
sur la conclusion de ça
ce que nous devons voir
c'est que
ce que la parole de Dieu nous dit
ce que la parole de Dieu
nous recommande
c'est que
nous devons toujours être dans une attitude
où nous sommes en train d'examiner les choses
nous sommes en train d'examiner les choses
pour voir
est-ce que ce que nous sommes en train de faire
est conforme à ce que la parole de Dieu recommande
et lorsqu'on va parler du travail des diacres
nous allons voir un moment que
dans plusieurs passages de la Bible
la Bible est claire
sur ce que Dieu attend du rôle des diacres
les diacres sont là pour être en soutien
au travail pastoral
au travail des pasteurs
le diacre va être là pour le soutenir
pour le soulager de certaines tâches
et
ce que nous sommes en train de dire
c'est que
on n'est pas en train de dire
que le diacre est là
pour être dans une obéissance
aveugle
aux pasteurs
et
chaque fois
ce qui est recommandé
quand nous lisons acte 17
nous
en prenant l'exemple des chrétiens de Béret
on voyait que les chrétiens de Béret
avaient reçu la parole
avec beaucoup d'empressement
et ils examinaient chaque jour
les écritures
pour voir
si ce qu'on leur disait était exact
donc là il y a aussi ce souci
chaque fois
de toujours être guidé par la parole
de s'assurer que
les diacres
les anciens et les diacres
sont en train de travailler ensemble
pour que chaque fois
l'autorité de la parole
soit placée au dessus de toute chose
gloire à Dieu
et puis
on va voir
les diacres
et les diacres
sont en train de travailler